don't you think it would have been
important for the Congress to know back
in January when we were first briefed on
this Trump dossier that it was actually
paid for by the opposition party so the
people that made the Russians successful
are the Democrats and the people who
have continued this nonsense over and
over and over again looking for Russians
behind every tree the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee Devin Nunez
giving his thoughts on the fake news
anti-trump dossier that was funded by
the Clinton campaign and the DNC only
one of those scandals now surrounding
the entire Democratic Party Hillary
Clinton the media the other being of
course the uranium one deal involving
allegations now a bribery and corruption
and kickbacks in all sorts of other
things
joining us now well he was the first
person who exposed the Iranian one issue
the author of the number one New York
Times bestseller Clinton cash is also
the president of the Government
Accountability Institute Peter
Schweitzer it's is it worse than what
you knew at the time and as much as how
the government actually knew about all
of these crimes committed by Putin
operatives inside the country did you
know that part it is yes it is Sean
although I'll say it's very interesting
to see what this so witness is going to
tell us about bribery because it's worth
recalling that uranium one this company
started in 2005 and it started when the
Clintons helped this Canadian
billionaire acquire uranium assets in
Kazakhstan Bill Clinton went over there
he sweet-talked the dictator Nazarbayev
what was Hillary Clinton's role what we
actually have testimony in the form of a
deposition from the guy running the
Kazakh uranium program at the time
Mukhtar Jacques Chev and he says that
the Kazakh Prime Minister went to the US
Senate wanted to meet with Hillary
Clinton who is on the Senate Armed
Services Committee and she refused to
meet with him until the uranium
concession was granted so we already
have this case of pressure and then
after Giustra got this uranium
concession he gave 30 million dollars to
the Clinton Foundation
was washed through Latvia or some other
placing and and I was actually Russia
paying the Clinton Foundation because
that's where my that we know there's
money laundering yeah that that that
comes later that's part of this the
current scandal that I think the
eyewitnesses who testified to but the
point is is that that we already have
testimony from foreign government
officials that there was pressure we
know that as soon as Giustra got this
uranium concession he said his first
donation ever thirty million dollars to
the Clinton Foundation and it sort of
took off from there so when Hillary
Clinton says in 2010 a couple of years
later uranium one this Russia deal I
didn't know anything about it she was
intimately involved with this company
over the last five years and we have
testimony of foreign officials and so
let me bring in former deputy assistant
to the president president Trump
Sebastian quark I didn't mean to
introduce you and I just got ahead of
myself as I want to do I apologize dr.
Gork I want to look big picture here
and I thought Sarah Sanders said this
very well and I take it a step further
everything that they tried to say about
Donald Trump and his campaign they are
guilty of but I'll add on steroids and
human growth hormone that they sold out
America's security in this case give me
the big picture take away from this
because now the media's gone silent on
Russia virtually silent here's the big
picture take away Sean for more than a
year the fake news industrial complex
and the Democrats and Hillary and
Podesta and Ben Rhodes have been
slinging filth against the president and
against his team none of it has stuck
but in the last week we have had an
explosion of scandals that all are true
and that all go back to the DNC and to
Hillary and the trouble is Sean you have
to do a massive service because you're
the only people it's you it's Sarah it's
Solomon it's Peter
but that's it and there's so many
scandals we have to separate them number
one there's a uranium one deal that's
treasonous okay we have to deal with
that
and there's the dodgy dossier which is
about Russian disinformation being used
to slander Donald Trump and then thirdly
there's James Comey using that
disinformation to create a special
prosecutor trigger that is used to
investigate the president and then
lastly the fourth story is future and
GPS how many stories are out there that
are fake that came from Moscow and which
were peddled by fusion GPS into the
left-wing media that's for scandals in
one week short that the Russians lied to
impact the election the Russians
infiltrated our national security in two
corner of the uranium market and they
succeeded and they knew all the crimes
that were committed if this had happened
in the 1950s there would be people up on
treason charges right now the Rosenbergs
okay this is equivalent to what the
Rosenbergs did and those people got the
chair think about it giving away nuclear
capability to our enemies that's what
we're talking about
all right last word our friend Peter
well look I think it's going to be
amazingly important for that information
to be preserved by the FBI
I think this iWitness needs to be
protected and I think we're gonna see a
lot more coming out on Clinton
pay-to-play and I think Gregg Jarrett is
right there's major legal problems for
the Clintons when it comes to violating
federal law I got to tell you it is the
most unbelievable
it's almost if it was a novel I wouldn't
believe it
it takes you that far selling out
national security them literally using
Russian lies to impact the election
propagandizing the American people you
guys have been phenomenal good work
we're gonna stay on it thank you both we